tears of the Kingdom has two endings
kind of one is the normal ending for
completing the game and one is the true
or secret ending which is the normal
ending plus an extra cutscene after the
credits now the story and endings may
not be as ambiguous or confusing in
Zelda as they are in say Elden ring
where I have explained endings before
but there are enough moving parts that I
think an explanation video will help
piece everything together there's a lot
more to say about this game than there
was in breath of the wild so I want to
put together a clear narrative in this
video feel free to subscribe to the
channel if I do a good job and obviously
big spoiler warning I think a good
starting point for our discussion is the
end sequence of the game when you
Journey Into the Depths under Hyrule
castle and begin the final boss fight if
you completed all of the sage quests
then the five sages of the current age
will join you Tulin sidon unibo reju and
mineru you all fight the small mobs and
eventually each one of their respective
scourges show up the sages find their
respective match and leave you link to
go forward and confront Demon King
Ganondorf as we enter the lair we find
shriveled up Ganondorf sitting atop a
tree stump the whole room is covered
covered in Roots evoking the spreading
of his Gloom throughout the lands of
Hyrule it also connects back to when we
first woke up after being attacked at
the beginning of the game the room link
wakes up in on the great sky island is
similarly covered in Roots and branches
and in typical evil villain fashion
Ganon monologues about how peace is bad
before transforming into his original
Warrior form granted he does have the
secret Stone in his forehead but beyond
that it's how he looked as a normal
Gerudo we engage in single combat with a
demon king before he goes full-on anime
literal this is only a fraction of my
power extending his health bar across
the screen looking like a glitch type
Anime Transformation there isn't much to
explain with this sequence other than
its Ganondorf recharging the power that
was sealed Away by rauru and that power
is getting strengthened by the secret
stone that Ganon still has after the
transformation the sages slowly trickle
in only to be knocked out by a power
Blast from Mister continues to be super
anime fingertaunt then it's back to one
on one but even with all the gloom and
heartbreaking Ganondorf is no match for
link the master sword and gibdo
bone-infused arrows however Ganondorf
has dedicated his entire existence to
conquering so defeat is not something
he's prepared for instead of accepting
his loss he rips the secret Stone from
his forehead gives up having a
Consciousness and eats the stone along
with half of his forearm the practice of
eating secret Stones leads to
draconification becoming a dragon
in the game's fifth listed memory minaru
says that to swallow a secret stone is
to become an immortal Dragon one blessed
with eternal life
she also says to become an immortal
dragon is to lose oneself she says that
doing so causes the user to lose their
heart and mind to lose what makes you
you and we see this in action with Zelda
who swallows her secret Stone and in a
massive explosion of light becomes an
immortal Dragon Zelda did this so she
could bathe the master sword in sacred
energy for centuries so that it would be
strong enough to defeat Ganondorf by the
time link could wield it but back in our
present time Ganondorf does not seek to
become a dragon for the benefit of
longevity he eats the stone because he
cannot bear to lose so he thinks turning
into a dragon will bring the power
upgrade he needs to cast the world into
Eternal Night and fitting with his dark
Powers the stone turns him into a demon
dragon fortunately a much smaller Dragon
Zelda is around to help link out and fun
fact when we first start the game we can
see Zelda flying around the great sky
island so it doesn't seem that
draconification fully nullifies the
person who swallowed the stone since
Dragon Ganon still wants to destroy the
war world and dragon Zelda still wants
to help link stop him we end the game
just as we began it flying through the
air link Must Destroy each of the groups
of Gloom eyes on the demon dragon's back
before finally attacking a super-sized
secret Stone on its forehead from a few
sacred light infused attacks the stone
shatters and Ganon vaporizes in a
planet-shaking explosion of red light
well that does it for the main villain
we still get a fair bit more in terms of
cutscenes and plot conclusion before the
curtain closes after the explosion as
link rides on the light dragon his arm
the arm of raru glows it envelops him
taking him and the dragon into a realm
of blue green light reminiscent of the
shrines rauru's power and the echo of
Zelda we saw at the beginning of the
game
the arm sends small bits of light to
Dragon Zelda as the spirits of rauru and
Sonia appear we will get more
information in the final cutscene about
how Spirits work so for now I'll just
take that aspect at face value once raru
and Sonia appear the arm starts sending
more light and as both of them put their
arms on links even more light energy is
sent to the dragon this ends up
transforming the dragon back into Zelda
just as she was before she transformed
during the time of the zonai she is in
the zonai clothing and even still has
her secret Stone we can't say exactly
how it was that Zelda's draconification
process was reversed but it is likely
due to the specific powers of everyone
involved Zelda herself had power of time
and of sacred light from his Hylian
lineage and or his new arm link probably
has light and time power too after
touching the echo of Zelda he is able to
reverse time with his arm which is not
something we ever see rauru do and he
has been bathed in light at every Shrine
he has visited plus he is the first one
sending energy to Zelda then we have
raru who has light power and Sonia who
has time power raru is a zonai who
minaru tells us came from the heavens
and were said to be descendants of gods
this information plus the existence of a
goddess statue in the Temple of Time May
draw a connection between rauru and the
goddess hylia hylia is the goddess
referenced by the game statue and the
namesake for plenty of landmarks around
Hyrule in past games she is referenced
as the goddess of Light which would give
us another connection for raru Link's
dilia would help explain the ability to
deed draconify Zelda as hylia would be
one of the most powerful entities in
existence plus the dragons come about
from the secret Stones which the murals
depict as coming from the heavens with
the zonai if the stones are of the
heavens then it makes sense that
influence from hylia being the goddess
could impact them even alter their
effects we can also see a Hylian
influence in Sonia there are quite a few
parallels to be drawn between Sonia and
Zelda being part of the royal family
Zelda is Sonia's descendant and Sonia
confirms this by saying that she feels
her own time power along with rauru's
light power within Zelda other Zelda
lore says that the first Zelda was a
mortal Reincarnation of hylia and that
each future Zelda is a descendant of
that Zelda if the Zelda of Tears of the
kingdom is also a descendant of Sonia
this could mean that Sonia is a
descendant of the Mortal hylia too and
we do have another piece of connection
to the gods that all four of these
characters share Sonia Zelda and Link
all have characteristically long Hylian
ears raru being a goat person zonai has
even longer ears in the manual to a link
to the past and in the Hyrule Historia
long pointed ears are associated with
the gods and goddesses specifically to
listening for special messages from
these Divine beings all this connection
to hylia and the realm of the Gods
should give some justification for how
Zelda is able to be turned back she was
first transformed by a Stone from the
Heavens to a mix of heavenly power
undoing this transformation seems
reasonable even if we were told that it
should be impossible another detail that
is easy to miss in the Big Flash
untransformation is that Link's arm is
healed too he no longer has the raru arm
but his original Hylian arm or some
Recreation of It Now link never ate a
heaven Stone he just got bodied by some
gloomy darkness and with all the time
and light power flowing it's not too big
of a task to heal some normal flesh it
definitely doesn't need as much
justification as the reversal of an
irreversible draconification process so
I think we can say it makes sense with
that raru and Sonia Fade Away in some
form of spirit passing on moment link is
sent back to the normal sky and races to
catch a falling and unconscious Zelda he
catches her and the two land in the lake
from the game's beginning and then we
get the standard final cutscene Zelda
with her secret Stone intact takes in
what has happened she realizes Ganondorf
has been defeated and she kind of
awkwardly speaks to us well ostensibly
link by staring directly into the camera
she mentions that she woke up from
Dragon City sleep after feeling a warm
loving Embrace which we can interpret as
the power from link raru and Sonia
Hyrule Castle still sits up in the air
hoisted by a Chasm pillar and Zelda
closes out the normal ending of the game
with an almost cliched warmth
then after the credits we get the true
or secret or final cutscene the Gang has
made their way to the flying temple of
time to see Spirit mineral off minaru
super briefly explains that rauru's
light power and Sonia's time power
channeled through link to turn Zelda
back but we saw before that there does
seem to be more of a justification for
the action than just that after saying
so minaru begins to fade she notes that
she can move on join raru and the others
others and the world will be safe
this could just be talking about playing
dying but the language really makes it
seem like passing to an afterlife or
some other plane of existence maybe the
spirits of raru and Sonia had not passed
on since they knew the threat of their
time the demon king had not been stopped
or they felt they had a duty to return
Zelda to her original form we did
previously get some Spirit interaction
with rauru at the beginning of the game
and we could have attributed that to the
arm and its power but this seems to show
that there is some more depth to the
spirit side of things in this world
the sages then assembled to pledge their
fealty and support to Zelda in a
touching callback to the actions of the
first group of sages we can also see
they all still have their secret Stones
we don't see zeldas in this cutscene but
after seeing it in the first we should
expect that she still has it or it's
still somewhere around it's also a bit
interesting to see that all the sages
are more developed and grown versions of
those we helped in breath of the wild
other than Tulin who is still a
youngling to be fair he's not as much of
a baby as he was in the last game but he
is very much more of a child than his
father Teba who previously served as the
Rito companion miniru says rauru and
Sonia will be happy to hear of the field
he pledge which confirms that there is
some spear playing that they're all
possibly chilling at having a ball
hopefully Ganondorf Spirit doesn't go to
the same place or things would be pretty
awkward to say the least miniru assures
Zelda that she'll tell Sonia and raru
how much Zelda cares for them and then
she fully disappears along with her
secret Stone this means there are only
five secret Stones left at least that we
know of and as someone of an aside roru
and Sonia standing as parental figures
for Zelda really drives home The
Descendant point I talked about before
and this also confirms again the
post-death plane of existence where they
have some sort of Consciousness and they
can communicate with each other then
Zelda finishes the scene with a speech
about establishing an eternally lasting
piece before the camera pans out and the
soundtrack kicks in with a rendition of
the main Zelda theme which of course
doesn't play long enough
[Applause]
and thus ends Zelda tears of the Kingdom
I do have one more point to make
regarding the hylia connections though
some of the design for Ganondorf in this
game really look like a reference to
demise the antagonist from Wind Waker
and kind of an evil counterpart to the
goddess hylia and the place where
Ganondorf launches his original attack
onto Hyrule is even called the breach of
demise in the maps for breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom I figured
this was one more piece of Zelda lore
that made its way into this game and
kind of reinforces the connection to
hylia and with that we should have the
core points of the true ending to tears
of the Kingdom covered and explained a
huge thank you and shout out to my
fellow video maker V limit Who as a
one-man Army of Zelda lore helped me
flesh out lots of the ideas in this
video he makes super high quality
content and I definitely recommend you
check out his channel I'll be doing more
Zelda videos so subscribe if you want to
see that and lastly a big thanks to my
patrons on patreon for supporting my
work thanks for watching everyone peace